hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
seriously smartphones we've been
tracking down the engineers who say it's
time for an alternative London is dot
live why Britain's capital has a new
domain name can you crack the code the
YouTube videos that have got people
talking and spider-man is swinging back
into action in this week's games review
when it comes to smartphones most of us
tend to gravitate towards a few key
brands but if you want to use the
technology are you limited to the likes
of iPhone or Nexus as heat dispensers
mean finding out it's not just
engineering enthusiasts who are looking
for alternatives we have my latest we
just forget about the iPhone how about
app iPhone taking the raspberry pi's
cheap and cheerful board computer as a
starting point for less than a hundred
pounds software engineer dave hunt
managed to build his very own smartphone
he isn't the only one who's
experimenting while there's no disputing
that iOS and Android dominate the
smartphone market a growing number of
enthusiasts are choosing to go their own
way and if you're confident enough to
risk in validating your warranty
installing what's known as a custom ROM
can mean greater control and the ability
to use a mobile without the restraints
of the carrier but with most of us
lacking the technical know-how to
experiment just how much of a choice do
we really have there are free and open
alternatives and there have been four in
many many years I mean the free software
movement has been going for thirty years
but it is inaccessible to regular people
and one of the greatest challenges of
our time is to make free and open
technology accessible to mere mortals at
the Brighton offices of Indy phone this
fledgling tech startup is hoping to
ruffle a few feathers started following
whistleblower Edward Snowden's
spying revelations the company is
building a smartphone which promises to
free users from corporate surveillance
by decentralizing personal data making
it harder for third parties to get to we
are pretty much aware that the
government really shouldn't have all
this information right but why should
corporations have them why do we trust
their motives more ideally you should be
the only one who has an information
unless you want to share it so if you
want something to be private it should
be for your eyes only
but does the company really stand a
chance of competing against the big boys
the trouble is is that of course it's
hard for other vendors to really compete
with the marketing clout and an existing
brand appeal these firms have with their
devices so whether or not competitors
the kitronik break into the market can
can do that hard to tell clearly the
biggest smartphone names will take some
toppling but critics argue we could all
benefit from having greater choice
Katie Spencer Sky News you watching
swype coming up spider-man is swinging
back into action but first what does
London have in common with New York
Berlin and Vienna the nightlife museums
coffee yes but also now it's joined a
list of cities that have got or soon
will be getting their own domain name
for web addresses dot London is here but
is it any good
dozens been finding out we all know
dot-com and co dot UK but now there's a
new kid on the block dots London follows
in the footsteps of dot NYC which went
live in March
London officials are confident the new
domain name will prove popular in an age
of town specific currencies where
there's a desire to think and by local
people you know long for a sense of
place on the internet there are quite a
lot of apps and software now which is
about locating yourself
well that's business-wise or
individually and so we think the time is
right now for a global city like London
to take its place if you like on the
internet injecting really for the first
time this kind of sense of urban
geography and of course it will make the
money organizations businesses and
individuals in the city can now
for a dot London address companies that
sell them say there have been 50,000
expressions of interest not all reaction
has been positive though critics say
dot-com gives you an easier to remember
address with a global presence and
there's another problem the way we use
the web has changed people use search
engines effectively as browsers so that
will type it in there's no need to
change an Avalon in it if you are it
knows where you are because you can see
you know you understand where your
computer or your mobile phone smartphone
is so all you need is the name of the
business which is a fair point when was
the last time you manually typed in a
web address some companies are already
using dot London alongside their
previous websites notable examples being
upmarket retailer Fortnum and Mason's
and West Ham football club other
companies with a dot London domain name
insist it will be useful we're exporting
to say 30 35 different countries and
when they think of like the UK they tend
to think of London what with the last
couple of years London really really
being at the the heart of what's going
on than when the world really would the
the games that happened and everything
it was a great chance for us to
highlight our London credentials to to
those markets Londoners are being given
priority to apply for the new addresses
for the next three months they cost
around 50 pounds money raised from the
sales will be used to promote London
tourism and business around the world
Stuart Duggan Sky News you're watching
swype coming up can you crack the code
the YouTube videos that have got people
talking but first ever wanted what the
astronauts will wear when they
eventually fly to Mars well the US Space
Agency NASA has revealed all as swipes
been finding out the suit as we said
he's evolving they're going through
slowly they can carry out lots of tests
they'll be having volunteers working
inside the suits inside a vacuum chamber
and they're also going to be testing it
out on simulated Mars area so that
they'll be working out amongst the rocks
and dust
and checking how the suit stands up to
that it's an evolutionary design they
produced a previous one Z 1 this is Z 2
and elements of this will be
incorporated into this designer said 3
it's much further from the Sun if you're
lucky in the summer at the equator on
Mars you might get up to about freezing
morning so the temperature is a major
factor the suit has to protect you
against that it has to keep you warm it
also has to protect you against the fact
that it's very very low atmosphere it's
pretty much close to a vacuum so you
need protection against that also the
suit has to provide the wearer with
oxygen take away their carbon dioxide
you've got to include a radio so you can
keep in contact with your fellow
astronauts unlike the Apollo missions
where they were out on the the surface
of the Moon for up to three days at a
time
we're expecting Nationals to be
exploring Mars for weeks months and so
cool so the soup has to be very robust
coming up we've a few dark fairy tales
on this week's games review but first
it's a roundup of anything you might
have missed over the last few days it
had been rumored for a while now
Facebook has launched its audience
network
Mark Zuckerberg revealed his plans at
the f8 Developers Conference in San
Francisco the idea is to serve ads to
third-party apps which Facebook promises
should be more relevant to the user
through Facebook data yahoo has
announced it's moving into program
making commissioning two of its own
original TV series little air on its web
sites and mobile app the shows will be
comedies ones called other space the
other Sin City Saints it follows the
lead of sites like Netflix Amazon and
Hulu which already make their own
digital video content meanwhile when it
comes to watching movies on the move the
big boss of DreamWorks believes will
soon be paying
in Ch Jeffrey Katzenberg from the studio
which gave us animated grapes like Kung
Fu Panda and Shrek set out his vision of
the future at a conference in Beverly
Hills 10 years from now he says he
expects a movie to be available on all
platforms within 18 days not only that
but he thinks we'll be prepared to pay
more for screen size in other words
it'll be cheaper to watch on a
smartphone but on your TV it's a new way
to pay backed by most of Britain's major
banks pam has had a fairly strong launch
in the UK with 360,000 people
registering for the service in the last
week the idea is you can pay back
someone you know using just their mobile
phone number although some people have
been a little nervous that it looks a
little bit too easy the payments council
has said all banks using the service
have signed up to strict security
standards and finally the conspiracy
theorists have been getting overexcited
this week with much debate taking place
over these YouTube videos more than
77,000 have been posted online each only
11 seconds long nobody seems to be able
to track down the person behind the
mysterious webdriver torso account so
naturally that's led to wild speculation
over what on earth it could be could it
be a form of superspy communication or
just a code who knows one thing that is
for sure is that it is rather annoying
so please just make it stop
much better now this week if you're a
gamer there are a host of exciting and
entertaining titles that are worth
checking out from dark fairy tales to
some familiar film franchises Lucy James
has been giving us her picks
child of light is the latest game from
Ubisoft Montreal it's this gorgeous 2d
artwork it looks it basically looks like
a child's picture book and you play as a
little girl named Aurora and she's she's
kidnapped from her father and she's
putting this gorgeous lund called
lumeria
and she has to basically get all the
light back from the evil queen of the
night everything's done in a poem all of
the speech everything's this one long
poem and it's a gorgeous story and it's
all about her you follow her she grows
up and she has all these friends that
you know they'll band together and they
have to deal with all these nightmares
that they find in the land of Lemuria
the gameplay is pretty cool as well it's
sort of like a Japanese role-playing
game you have a little timeline on the
bottom and you have to predict your
attacks before and getting hit in before
the enemy does it's all about you know
really taking your time and figuring out
where things are gonna go on a timeline
so you can get a bit complicated child
awhite is really gorgeous it's
downloadable only game at the moment but
it really is and you know it's one of
those games where the artwork really
stands out and the music as well
everything ties together really
beautifully they like the first kind of
big title to be released using the
Unreal 4 engine which for gamers is
really exciting because it's a very
technologically advanced engine that a
lot of other bigger games are going to
be built in adayla it's pretty small you
can finish it in a few hours it's a
horror game and every encounter is
different so it'll play out differently
every time you play whether it's the the
rooms that get created or the enemy
encounters you'll have you play as woman
named Sarah and she wakes up in an
abandoned asylum but you can let the
classic horror game setting what's
really cool about daylight is it's kind
of built with twitch in minds that which
is an online platform where people can
play video games and broadcast them over
the Internet daylights built so that
people in the chat logs while they're
watching the game can input commands and
a directly affect the way that the
gamers levels play out it'll be
interesting to see how the community all
works together to figure out what these
commands are and how they can terrify
the bejesus out of people playing this
game
Octodad dadliest catch is it's out of
the ps4 now it's a sequel to a game dude
that was just made by a bunch of
students and it's got a really unique
premise and that you play as an octopus
who's trying to masquerade as a human he
was a lovely 3-piece suit and his his
arms and his legs are you know his
tentacles and it even is all mustaches
made of his tentacles but he's really
cute
but the thing is obviously doesn't have
bones which makes kind of getting around
quite difficult and also he sticks to
things so you're trying to control this
octopus that's flailing around name of
the game is to not get recognized as an
octopus you have to try and be a human
so he's kind of put into everyday
situations like taking his family to the
aquarium or going shopping on mowing the
lawn it's just a crazy kind of
experience it's a very unique gaming
experience but it's very funny amazing
spider-man 2 recently came out in
cinemas and there is a tie-in game to go
with its following the story of amazing
spider-man 2 the movie so you're Peter
Parker you're trying to find Uncle Ben's
killer it's all very emotional but
they've introduced a whole bunch of new
features so when you shoot webbing out
it can you know either freeze or explode
enemies it's quite quite cool just
rather than just sticking an enemy to a
spot there's a lot of famous enemies you
know they'll be Green Goblin Kraven the
hunter kingpin even so they're kind of
doing something for the comic book fans
there as well Andrew Garfield sadly
isn't in it but it will have a good
hopefully a good story that's kind of
closely mirrors the movie that's it for
this week remember you can catch up with
all the breaking tech stories all week
on sky news for iPad our smartphone apps
and sky news comm see you next time bye
bye